today's episode is brought to you by
gray block
pizza gray block pizza
you know what it is baby boy get that
hitter
man my neck hurts
oh my neck hurts sometimes i feel you
know like just
i mean just like every i
feel this like all my emotions and
hopes and fears and everything are just
thumb wrestling
in the back of my neck that's where i
keep a lot of tension
you know that's how i you know i'm kind
of attention man
some people refer to me as attention man
you know when i was born the doctor said
oh he's taught
this baby's real talk you know you
couldn't
you know wasn't like a superman you know
some children they're real malleable
they'll come out foot first head first
they come out you know
sometimes they'll put a foot out and put
it back you know don't hang a foot out
and then pull it back in
like they're doing the you know the
hokey pokey
from you know from birth you put your
left foot in the world you take your
left foot you know and then there
shoulder first lean with it rock with it
and then
fat joe rolls right out of a womb you
know that's how
some babies are but that wasn't me
you know i was they i remember
reading and you know my mother kept a
lot of scripture and everything about my
birth and
different child memories and stuff like
that
uh even when she didn't have a camera i
remember there were some pages i have a
baby book
and my mother would draw a picture of me
having a good time or draw a picture of
me crying out on the porch
but i remember what it said in there
when i was born oh he the doctor said
he's
you know 11 pounds whatever but he's
taught
he's real real this baby is damn real
you know like he just a little well done
and that's kind of how i've always been
were you breech birth riley
i was not
all right man well let's there's
different ways to do it let's get into
the episode
[Music]
there's nothing left to see
you and me
[Music]
this time there's no danger you
found someone else told me
to be patient love will find its way
[Music]
look what's happened
on stevie's starlight ladies and
[Music]
gentlemen
and ladies and gentlemen right there
that's stevie's starlight
with time is no stranger
and that's off his new album unnaturally
happy
and you can go get that album and we'll
put a link on there
so you can grab that and get that sound
inside of you
yeah i was that taught baby i was that
taught baby
i've always been that taught baby you
know just
just taught you know just
you know i remember my mother was uh my
mother's always had riley mao's here
how are you today riley doing well it's
great to be here again
yep we're having you back man and you
know it's a trial basis and i hate to
say that
you know to you like that but that's
life
right exactly you know life's a trial
basis
and um how old are you i am 22
okay so so you're 22 years into the
trial of life really
true right and um and so yeah we're
gonna see and just see how people react
to you and
you know um but you know we're happy to
have you back for an episode and
and uh and we'll see how people kind of
react to you it's great to be back
yeah yeah yeah yeah um do you have any
birth defects or anything like that
um can't say i have um
i mean i'm a musician like i said but
know when you were born were you missing
anything did you have any birth defects
um dang dude i'm not sure i don't think
so
okay so straight up full birth yeah
wow must be nice man that's how it is
these days when i was young i'll tell
you this story when i was young people
were born you'd have a buddy missing a
uh
you know you'd have you'd have a buddy
missing a clavicle you know you'd have a
friend
you know it wasn't crazy to shake
somebody's hand and only feel four on
them
you know it was a different time
somebody people were uneven
right somebody missing half of cossacks
or half of a damn
you know have a square occipital orbital
entrance you know somebody you know have
a damn square eye
it was just different times people had
rabies uh
what else they had people had diseases
uh you you know i grew up they had this
the tail end of polio you'd see somebody
dragging themselves down you know
dragging
you know maybe they had a cane or a cane
somebody got him a cane
that was too short and so they you know
somebody out there short cane
just barely might as well just
i mean look like you know might have
just dragged themselves if you're short
can it looks like you're doing damn
magic like you're out there just
you know right is it cosmeticus or
whatever
but anyway you never had asthma or
anything huh
i have not god man living in luxury
living in luxury we're coming out here
again this is um
episode two from the central east and
happy to be here with you today
uh what's going on
you know i've been doing the mma that's
what's really going on man and my body
just feels
i mean it's it's so you get in there
and yeah i'm still fighting the women
i'm fighting the women and it's
uh and they are man
i'm glad some of these women weren't my
mother because my mother put a good a
you know put a good a whooping on me
you know she beat i mean my mother kind
of lady she beat both cheeks she'll make
you pull on your pants afterwards to
make sure they're both red
not one of these one cheek wonders a lot
of these moms
they you know they get one cheek red and
they give up
my mom gonna burn up
both of your little bottom hillsides
baby that's how she was
you know she's a hard worker uh
but yeah what was i talking about
you know what i was talking about man by
chance i don't know
um you're talking about what's kent and
you were doing
mma oh yeah thank you so you're in there
and you got a man in your lap and you in
a man's lap and it's really
i mean it's just so it reminds me of
monkeys when you see
monkeys in a zoo or a penitentiary or
something if you've ever been in one of
those
you know animal prisons in um
uh bali you know in bali they have so
many monkeys that a lot of them have
gone and they put them in the
detention the bad ones they put them
into detention centers have you seen any
of this
uh raleigh i have yeah and so when you
look at that kind of stuff and you see
the bad ones what do you
you support that kind of thing i mean
they're they're monkeys
yeah yeah i support all monkeys whether
they're
whether they're bad or not
yeah and well yeah i mean i guess that's
one way to do it but
for me if you're already a monkey that's
risque for me
and then if you are a bad one at that
point
you know i'm not trying to take one of
god's animals out of commission but we
gotta
we gotta thin the hurt a little bit you
know
you're a bad monkey and they're having
detention centers for you it's too much
for me
for me at a certain point you gotta stop
the bus
but um anyway but yeah you get out there
you doing the mma and i'm over there and
there's like
you know people are being really helpful
it's definitely
you know they'll have somebody will show
you the same move 30 times
and i'll be in there for for an hour and
all i learned was
i don't i can't even explain you what i
learned like how to roll over
okay you know it's almost
uh something you would see a strong baby
do
everybody's behaving like animals
they're behaving like it reminds you of
when you see the chimpanzees
when you see the little mon you know the
mono tantos you know
the crazy monkeys whatever you know
that's how they're doing
some are sitting on the side just kind
of watching a couple of them are rolling
around you're grabbing each other's feet
and neck
you know that sort of thing um and it's
wild man my
the tips of my fingers are all sore
almost like i've been playing the guitar
the instrument that i'm playing really
is
it's you're playing like another person
really but
the instrument that i'm playing is
it's almost like i'm playing my own
i don't want to say confidence but i've
been pl it's like um
it's like give these little scars from
playing your own
i can't really think of it but that's
what him
that's what it is you're just on the
ground you're just learning this thing
over and over again
you know when you're doing the mma so
have you taken any classes like that
riley do you have a uh
do you have a um extracurricular
thing that you do i do um i was in
taekwondo for
many years as a as a teen wow
and how uh did you guys train often or
were you under a certain sensei or
whatever
um yeah so it's this one location by my
house in anaheim
and um i would go there almost every day
after school and just
train like constantly and i made it up
to black belt
damn really yeah that was my like top
goal um same as eagle scout i made a lot
of people don't make its eagle scout i
made it to eagle scout
i made it to black belt now is there in
the eagle scouting process is there a
is there a letting is there like a
moment where it's like okay you guys are
all lined up and they say okay
you know william you're going to be an
eagle scout teresa you're going to be
one you know
you know anthony you're going to be one
and then you guys kind of step
forward and i i kind of picture these
other kids you know
you know this guy couldn't make a you
know couldn't make the whatever he
needed a
you know a edible shovel or whatever you
know the different merit badges he
couldn't do it and so he
has to is there a separation of the
you know of the haves and the have-nots
at a certain point
honestly um not really a separation
but it's more like um like hey if they
don't want to you know it's it's totally
their problem they don't have to
um but i know a lot of people a lot of
people
try to get to that point like at the
very beginning
i know they want that's why they join
scouting because they want to become an
eagle scout oh yeah
but later on once they like go through
all the hard work
and all the merit badges they're all
like you know i it's too much i give up
i have too much on my plate or like i
just don't want to do this anymore
yeah it's navy seals for fourth graders
it's navy seals for fourth graders
right essentially is there um
is there a is everybody cut out to be an
eagle scout
if i want to say yes and no
um yes if they have their mind set to it
then yeah they can be an eagle scout
it's not it's not too hard to the point
where it's impossible
it's always possible you just have to
just
just believe you have to apply yourself
and right apply yourself work for it
okay and is there a special was there
is there a finishing because
i'm just wondering how is there because
what i'm picturing is a moment
there's a night somewhere there's a
campfire there's a tent
and there's like you know a man comes in
everybody's wearing kerchiefs
and everybody which i like that style
you know i like the eagle scout style
first of all i like the
i like kind of the flare it's almost
like uh
bear grylls meets tgi fridays kind of in
a weird way you know how they have like
a lot of the
you know the medallions in that right
but
what i'm i just picture that there's a
night or by a campfire or something or
an extended cab
tent where people are saying you know
i'm i'm going on and you're not you know
and you're
i'm going into this other tent i'm uh
i'm i'm an eagle now and you are
what we blow is under eagle um no we
belows is
the bridge from cub scouts to boy scouts
okay and that's where you guys lose a
lot of people too huh right
yeah because a lot of people and i've
actually lost a lot of friends
from the not friends i mean you can say
it well i mean
they're still my friends but i've lost
them like going from cub scouts boy
scouts because they didn't want to
transition on wow
um but i mean you know it's totally
their choice i mean they're they're
doing well now
um i see all them are they i mean yeah
you see them on facebook do you see them
in the field of life do you see them
using the skills that you guys have
learned you know that's what because
that's where it matters man
you know that's what i'm saying when i
was young you
you came out of the womb yeah a lot of
people had to you know you had to boat
not your own damn umbilical cord
right you know there wasn't a man in
there now they cut your umbilical cord
they'll give a
you know the mail up you can mail they
got a website they'll mail a piece of a
teacher your grandparents that kind of
stuff you know
a little freaking uh you know that utero
caviar or whatever they're calling it
now and they all get together on a zoom
call and
all four of your grandparents eat a you
know do a shot of
uh you know greek whiskey or whatever
and
you know eat the babies and what you
know everybody you know eat the
umbilical cord at the same time you know
there's all these little group chats or
whatever but
when i was young it was different that's
what i'm trying to tell you brother
right um but that intro song was stevie
starlight man
that's unnaturally happy and uh
and man he's been with us since the
beginning of this show and he sent me a
nice email the other day
just checking in um
yeah what's going on man this week this
past week has been good it's been good
it's been
you know i had some moments where i was
really like
you know what am i doing how am i gonna
kind of make this work
this feels uncomfortable um
you know i had a day where i didn't want
to do anything
you know was really feeling uh down in
the dumps
um you know and thankfully there's mo i
have moments in that day where it's like
okay just
you know yeah maybe half the day hasn't
gone well but let's get the other half
let's salvage this other half of this
day and let's go
um you know one of the beauties of
of uh just so the past few years has
been meeting guys and being able to come
into worlds
um you know like
you know joe rogan you meet joe rogan
you get into his universe and know him
and you get inspired and then you start
you know following guys like david
goggins and reading their books and
jocko willink and
um and uh cam haynes and
and uh and you start getting
i guess it's like inspirational type of
guys you have dustin poirier come in and
sit down
you know um and you just
it it's interesting i start to realize
that i
i almost
thankfully i almost know too many people
now who don't give up
to give up like for like a full day
sometimes
if that makes any sense it's just like
uh
it it's like oh if you stack your deck
of cards with enough cards that
you know if you take some of the fives
out of your deck and you
throw in a couple extra jacks you know
something with a sword
you throw in an a couple extra jokers
you know
a couple extra beefy jokers you know
some riddler some juggler using
using test 200 or something and now you
got a deck of
you know you got a deck of cards that
are it's a little bit stronger it's a
little bit more like
inspirational i guess yeah i guess i've
just found myself getting more into you
know i know enough
inspirational people almost personally
um
where yeah it's just interesting it
almost makes it harder for me to give up
on myself a little bit
um so i don't know what i'm saying
really there
but what i was saying was i was just
yeah sometimes you have tough times but
i got some calls that were welcoming
um oh a man called me the n-word
i'll say that and it was a black man
uh black man called me the n-word and
i just i just said hey man you know it's
our time brother that's what i told him
i said it's our time to shine baby
you know blm daddy we can't be putting
each other down
um so
you know just interesting how do you how
do you deal with kind of inverse racism
a little bit
have you ever had to deal with anything
like this riley
um some uh sometimes a little with um
racism with being asian and all as a
child i mean now never
i mean even if i do i kind of laugh it
off as a joke because i mean i honestly
couldn't care less what people think
yeah um about that like i'm not i'm not
too sensitive about racism racism
to asians yeah um but
and asians handle things differently man
right you guys are really kind of like
you guys kind of bob and weave with the
racism i feel like
right you know and you know you guys you
know you look at asians there's and
there's also all different what i don't
like is get specific
with the racism these asians
you know i've said it i've definitely
said it i'll be honest with you oh yeah
everyone has yeah i mean i'm sure you
probably said
you know if people are behaving a
certain way i mean i stereotype all the
time
and i like it sometimes it doesn't mean
my heart is bad
right there's such a difference between
somebody who's out there sharpening a
sword
writing you know you know some
writing a name on it like writing a
black man's name or a
white man's name or an asian man's name
or something on it you know
this you know this sword is for you know
ladarius or something you know it's like
that's crazy
but if you're just like oh man dude
these asian people are driving me nuts
if say if you're stuck somewhere at a
festival or something like an asian
festival
that's not is that racism if everybody's
asian at the festival
not really yeah yeah and plus dude you
gotta look at
i believe that we all are gonna i
believe in beige power that's what i say
i believe we're all hurtling towards one
color eventually tone you and i are
probably the same skin tone
yeah about yeah getting there closer
i mean we're almost the same damn skin
tone man right
you know it's also yeah i don't know
what i'm talking about but
but yeah the guy called me the n-word i
don't know what to do you know and
honestly part of me
i was pretty excited i'll be honest with
you
you know i quit using the n-word
probably about four years ago when
everybody else did
fully i mean i would never actively you
know
but people would you know if i saw it in
a
sometimes people would do met you know
like you'd be playing that game of
will you draw something out of a hat and
you try to act out the movie
you know what that game is riley you've
ever played that in your town
um yeah charades yeah yeah definitely
trades and uh
are you good at charades no not at all
oh wow i wish i was
and what i would see was uh
people would write it in there right in
a racial slur or something
and so you'd pick it out and you start
acting it out and you're like oh
this isn't even a movie you know this is
racism
right so you know you'd see that old
trick but
anyway uh but yeah i shouldn't know how
to react
you know i didn't know how to react to
that and so i just
i figured one day we're all gonna be the
same thing
so i try to channel that energy from the
future
and say hey man
you know just accept the name just it's
our time baby
you know we're out here brother that's
what i said
and i tried to handle it as good as i
could you know because there's no
there's no correct way to handle that
kind of thing
kind of thing um
what else do we have going on man uh
what else is happening
uh what'd you do this week riley you
getting anything exciting
um just been editing some music videos
um
pretty much it and do you eat what do
you like to give
you eat regular meals and everything
right sometimes i mean i
sometimes like skip breakfast or lunch
because i'm just too busy editing
i'm too much in the zone or i'm just you
know laying back watching tv
now i find now this is one thing and
i'll get into a little bit of
racial discussion here i find that asian
people are good they
are very good at dropping into something
and just staying in the pocket
you go to some of these you know i've
been to uh
i've probably been in maybe seven asian
countries or whatever
and you'll go into some of these bank
these
a b uh buildings where there's just
thousands of uh asian people playing
video games until they die some of them
like it's just the uncanny ability to
drop into something
and stay there
i've honestly i haven't really thought
about that
for i mean for being from asians i've
never
really thought i mean i think that's
honestly just like it could be anybody
um i have a few friends that are like
that and
i mean they're definitely not asian
they're you know they're white but would
you be better than them could you beat
them if you guys were in a contest
it honestly it kind of depends um i'm
not one of those
like those gamers like those asian
gamers that you see that
are like right right there asian gamers
right exactly i'm not one of those guys
i mean are you a die-hard asian would
you say or not and this is just
i'm pretty much the whitest asian you
will meet
wow yep i mean well i mean not in terms
of my looks
but of my physical appearance but like
how my mindset works i didn't know you
were asian
really yeah oh well i am
all right let's take a call right here
hey seo man
it's nathan from nashville now it makes
me really excited to hear that you might
move
down here and i just want to offer a
perspective
thank you for calling nathan i
appreciate that brother sound like
you're reading does it sound like he's
written this and is reading it did you
pick up on that riley
sounds like it yeah thank you
about a year or so ago i was kind of
obsessed with moving to la
in my van with the idea of laying it all
on the line for my dream
and maybe by doing this god would you
know buy the ticket to the dream at the
price of
the ultimate sacrifice you know but um a
lot of my mentors here said they're like
dude just slow down you're kind of where
you need to be
and i just want to let you know man like
nashville's changing and growing
and if you move down here you'd kind of
be at the floor
the ground floor of a movement just well
first of all thank you man i appreciate
this call
young fella and i'll say this man
definitely
is getting a van and driving somewhere
apart is that laying it on the line
i guess in a lot of ways it is
you know you definitely you could easily
get fleas you're probably gonna at least
have a pet at some point
i don't trust the person that has the
van but not the pet that lives in it
with them
at least that guy i feel like is a
little bit more
non-murderer you know because you can't
murder
if you if you if you have a place if you
have a van
you're not going to bring some uh a
person home and murder him with the
animal right there
that because then there's two degrees of
what's going on
there's you being murderer and there's
the animal watching
that you know there's um there's just
so when i see a man with a van with no
animal
now a bird it doesn't count i'm talking
dog
a bird doesn't count a cat doesn't even
count a cat is just a
it's just a freaking uh
four-legged bird
and but when you get that animal if you
get a van with an animal
that guy aimer you know that guy will
try to screw you probably or do
sex with your give you you know and make
you a little grilled cheese or something
and maybe have you listen to a little
bit of widespread panic or something
like that and freaking
you know he'll want you you know he'll
do some henna tattoos on one of your ass
cheeks but he's not gonna
murder you but i feel like you get into
a van that has
no animal in it
that's murder town right there
what do you think riley you had any
experience with anything like that
i have not honestly
what else is going on man i'll say this
uh
i appreciate the call i appreciate the
call you calling and saying that good
things are here
things are happening let's hear a little
bit more of whatever you had to say
brother
to give you an example my band is a
psychedelic
gospel funk group and oddly enough we've
been
kind of welcomed and embraced and
again just things are moving and
changing it's not just well yeah
but i one way to get welcome and
abrasive if you if your band does
everything
you know we're a country uh
you know we're country zydeco
uh emo uh
drywall can we play here and it's like
yeah
you know sure you can you know as long
as you refinish the kitchen you can play
wherever you want
like if you have two if you have so many
options to a band
you know if you if you're like oh we do
acoustic acapello
uh jamaican um
sort of it's like kind of like a six
nine dixie chicks mashup then people are
like
uh they can't say no
so i think to challenge yourself brother
try one type of music
because if you got that christian disco
funk trap house
chop and screwed paul wall meets
uh paul simon
hell i don't even know what i'm at that
point i might as well just damn
you know drive my car into a damn amoeba
music
into an abandoned record shop but thank
you for the sentiment of this call
man and sentiment when you think of
sentiment
it's almost like cinnamon and mint
somebody put them together
let's hear the rest of this and oddly
enough we've been
kind of welcomed and embraced and um
again just things are moving and
changing it's not just country
right and asheville might not be known
for comedy
but man we could sure use a king down
here and you know music
and comedy go together like peanut
butter and jelly my friend
well i appreciate it man i appreciate it
man music and comedy are interesting you
know a lot of comedians
will end up getting into music
riley mao do you know that i do now
a lot of comedians will get into music
you know sinbad
is a famous kind of black asian kind of
comedian
and he does music now he has a band
steve martin famous
white man
uh you know he might have been italian i
don't know what he was but he also
he did music he does music now he plays
a banjo
jim brewer does music
he does music and he was you know
he definitely i mean he you know he
barely he seems like yeah
you know he's kind of a rescue kind of
man he
um a lot of a lot of communities get
into music
i think it's because at a certain point
sometimes you get
i think it's why anybody does anything
or changes it up
you know your voice and your your humor
become an instrument and then after a
while you're like i wanna i wanna play a
different instrument
you know i wish i could play the piano
i wish i you know because your voice and
your humor it's just a it's just the
it's just an instrument that's in you
some people's instrument in them is is
their voice
you know to sing some people is um
[Music]
you know uh do
you know um speed
you know def signaling
you know what what is that called you
know what i'm talking about riley
and hand gestures um
what's the name of it i think it's def
signaling but
but they have speed competitions now for
def signaling
you know you'll see you know the four
people are trying to rattle off
you know half of uh you know half of um
[Music]
you know flowers for algernon or
something they're just reading it as
fast as they can with their hands
but everybody's has a different you know
people have a different
play in a different instrument some
people may do bow and arrowing
and you just get it sometimes you're
tired you get tired you know
i don't want to do oh you know i don't
want to sing i want to try something
else
i want to try something else so i think
that's why a lot of comedians sometimes
will get into music eventually because
they want to play something else than
the instrument they've been playing
which is their sense of humor it's just
a refined instrument
that's all it is it's just like singing
but it's
just a little different i mean i mo at
least four times a day i think about
playing the piano
i just i'd like to play it
um so
but but yeah thank you for the nice call
man um
and we're actually i'm gonna uh i'm
gonna tell you right now i will be
performing
september 26th in cedar
rapids iowa and you can get those
tickets
uh theovonne.com uh you can check those
out
right there and i i appreciate the
support out there haven't been to iowa
i haven't been over there with the dark
arts tour over to iowa and
and um oh i got to tell you about this
real quick
today's episode is brought to you by
blue chew
blue tube you got to get your body going
you got to get if you want an erection
you got to get one that's the thing
and the you know in the old days you
could blow a uh
blow a flute and get erect
some countries you go over there you
know you go to india you go to the far
east you go to
you know botswana stand they blow the
flute
and you wiener gets hot gets erect you
snake up bro your wiener will bite a
freaking kid crawling by
you know but that but they but
you got to get somebody that can play
the flute you got to get the instrument
that's the more expensive deal
so ties have changed get the only
sildenafil and ted alfil
chewables by visiting bluechew.com
if you like sex or even just touching
your own body
when it's part of it's hard you'll love
bluechew.com
it offers men a performance enhancement
for the bedroom
the blue shoes can be taken on a fuller
empty stomach
so if you had a little bit of caviar or
if you you know
if you've never had caviar like me and
you pour bruh
and you've had a little bit of that gas
station caviar bro couple of
melted kitkats
then you can have this
right after you could do two kitkats and
still have a you know
and still get your wiener tightened up
so what i'm telling you here's a great
deal for you visit bluechew.com
and get your first order free when you
use promo code
t-h-e-o just pay five dollars shipping
that's b-l-u-e
promo code t-h-e-o
and that's important and i'll tell you
this also man it's that time of year and
i've been struggling with severe jock
itch
and it kind of is a little bit manly to
say i'll say it loud if there's some you
know
some hotties around i'll kind of just to
let them know
that um at least have a jock
you know even if it itches like at least
remind them hey i'm missing
but around you know this desirable route
manscaped however is on a mission to
change the grooming game
a lot of times jock itch is the
byproduct of having too much
you know hair around your body parts
your nuts and scrotum and everything
weiner
but that can change they just released
their products in the uk
canada and australia
so now you can get that good a tightened
up
you know now you can tighten up the
queen and the bait
and and whatever it's called the
unforgiving castle where the guy never
sleeps or whatever
and they keep walking by the tomb and
then the guy
um you know
he has the hat on you know what i'm
talking about
manscaped the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer
offers a replaceable ceramic
blade with advanced skin safe technology
which helps reduce grooming accidents
the waterproof technology also allows
you to groom in the shower now that's
nice
because usually what you got to do you
got to lay a trash bag in the garage you
got to get out there
drop a couple floodlights on the ground
and get at your bag and root
that's changed that has changed
the perfect package also comes with two
free gifts
and other liquid formulations to
complete your
body hair trimming routine you can
support the podcast and we need it
look we need the support so get twenty
percent off in free shipping at
manscape.com
t-h-e-o get twenty percent off and free
shipping at manscaped.com
theo upgrade that dong salon with the
luxury products
of manscaped
you have a lot of body hair rally i
don't
i would have guessed that man honestly
really yeah
and i hate to be now is that racism
if i guessed that you know what i'm
saying kind of right now i get it um
i don't kind of yeah i would think so
because asians you can't i mean you take
a razor with asian you barely get a damn
you know a quarter cup of hair probably
you probably you know you'll barely end
up with a damn sideburn on the ground
if you trim an asian so
they're kind of like the you know they
just they're not they're not hairy
people
are they are the yokozuna's hairy
i don't think so
that's a little okay i want to look that
up man
um we got another call that came in man
let's check it out right here
and this man had some nice stuff to say
onward
what's up mr vaughan you beautiful
bastard
uh listening to the latest episode man
here you're talking about
nashville and uh if i if i know anything
about that i would imagine that your
you're stressing and overthinking it bro
but i think you probably have the core
your fans
probably some of the most loyal fans in
the industry
i know that i got nothing but love for
you man i
know that a lot of others do too it
doesn't matter where you go if it's
bangladesh or boston bro
we're all here for you it don't matter
where you go so
know that know that your your fan base
is lawyer we're going to follow you
everywhere
and uh if you go to nashville man you're
a little closer to me in the uh
indy louisville area so uh spread your
wings bro
discomfort is where we get our greatest
achievements at
is when we kind of shake things up a
little bit so
spread your wings little birdie fly much
love homie
gang bro yeah man you're right man
leaning into the fear
you know leaning into the fear man
you're really that's a really nice
message man i appreciate i
appreciate you saying that and
yeah you know i'm really i i am so lucky
to to have people that care
you know uh and people remind me all the
time constantly through this podcast and
just nice people that i met and
yeah it never ends man um
you know it thanks man that's nice you
to say dude uh
yeah leaning into that discomfort
what's over here
it's so hard to sit sometimes with you
with your discomfort
it's so hard to sit there
and hear the sounds of your truth
or your truths just echoing
to you
yes uh thank you man
thank you for that that's nice uh it's
just it's a sweet message man
you know we have a lot of nice people
listen to this podcast
riley mao
all right um
oh i remember this man you know
halloween is coming up
and i remember that uh riley i wanted to
ask you
what you thought about that do you guys
practice that
what is some of your experience with
that um
honestly uh i don't have an opinion
i don't honestly all right
um do you remember ever being costumed
as a child did anybody dress you up and
kind of trick you out at different areas
for sugar you know what i'm talking
about halloween
but you know what i'm talking about yes
okay for sure but have you experienced
it did you
did you were you costumed up what do you
mean by that
did you dress up or yes okay and what
were some of the outfits or the
different styles or something oh man um
anything that really
that kind of stands out in your life
that you enjoyed i remember i was
spongebob
okay spongebob was great um i remember i
was a three-legged man and no one could
tell which one was the right
or was the fake leg so that was pretty
funny
that's a dirty grandpa's trick right
there too you know yeah
um that sounds fun though
it was really fun i i actually enjoy it
i always love halloween
um i've been using the blues brothers
right
yes so i i've been ellwood blue actually
no i haven't actually actually lied
about that yeah i'm sorry
you should watch it um but yeah i used
to be
asian ellwood blues um i was
did you watch the office yes okay
remember asian gym
it's like one of the later episodes or
one of the latest i didn't watch all of
it yet i'm actually
i'm on season one oh gotcha okay well
it's fantastic
um there was one episode where he um
where jim tried to trick um dwight
and like have like an asian gym and
trying to trick dwight into being like
no like that's really me
i've been here the whole time oh um so i
was asian jim
oh i like that i met jim one night at a
club one time really at a
like uh yeah and he was drinking and
chasing women i remember
and really hard up for a little bit of
cooch man at the time and so was i
and i could see in his eyes just
something that i saw in myself you know
and
uh
yeah i just i just remember that but um
yeah i remember halloween was so big and
we're young man
mom would get us out there
and man we would sometimes you know like
uh
i remember my sister was in like a cast
or something one time for something
she lost a battle with you know some
ants or something or
you know you know she tried to get artsy
with a
with a group of wasps and came in second
place you know
and um and so she was in one of those
kind of full body soft cast
where they really just trying to get
that aloe vera on you
where they kind of they almost have to
embal you know like uh
like a mummify you with aloe vera strips
of lotion and
you know in wax paper or whatever but um
i remember we took her around one time
we had to take her in like a little
wheelbarrow to go get the candy
uh we were one time we tried to be light
we thought light was like the really
bright white thing so we covered our
bodies with the
flower and went door to door like that
um my brother went through a phase kind
of like uh he
he would take a mirror and he would like
wheel it up to their door
and and they'd be like what are you what
are you you know he'd be like you don't
want to look at
who you really are you know he was like
uh
he was just going through a phase you
know
you know i'm the scariest thing you know
yourself you know
your truth like that kind of kind of
edgar allan poe kind of benjamin
franklin um
but god i remember it though i remember
just going door to door and there was
always a lot of pedophiles out
there was always a lot of pedophiles out
living their life and doing their thing
and that was there
you'd see them out with no kids
you know dressed up like a pedophile
you're like oh this is
this is interesting so
um but yeah man leaning into the fear
i'ma lean into the fear man and lean
into the uncomfort
you know i didn't even know about you
know having riley back what it was like
and what
you know we're you know just figuring
this all out and
[Music]
and you know even last week we kind of
talked at the end of the episode about
you know i just like trying something
new
it's hard to try new things sometimes
why does comfort feel so
man it's weird because comfort it's a
good thing right it's a positive word
it's a positive feeling but it's such a
too much of it is is you know it's
it can be a hampering this is
you know what i'm saying riley no
exactly i totally get what you're saying
have you been uncomfortable in your life
before oh many times
for sure um whether it's you know just
being on stage
um during one of my band performances uh
oh you're in a band
oh yeah oh you know that i was in um you
were in band right yeah i was in
uh marching band concert band jazz band
um pep bands damn um i yeah i love being
in band
and what's the heaviest instrument you
could carry you think um i
actually i think the heaviest one was i
was i remember i was in drumline and i
was carrying the
um you know the quads the um
like the the oh yeah the four drops
right the four or five drums
yeah i carried that that was really
heavy then again like right now i'm five
five i was like maybe
four eleven or something or like five
feet
and it was it was tough because i smoke
a blunt to that man watching a little
you know a smaller unique person of
color kind of carry a drum set dog
right i'd get high out of that i mean i
was the only asian i was the smallest
guy
on the team i it was it was tough but i
did it you were fierce almost really
right and it was actually kind of too
heavy to the point where i actually had
to move to a different instrument
um so i went on the smallest bass drum
there was you know how there's like
there's like different size bass drums
and drum line i was the smallest
bass drum oh wow that beautiful little
baby base huh exactly damn
and could you hit it pretty hard with
the sticks how many sticks did you get
two
one on each side oh hell yeah yeah yeah
yeah cause we had a guy in ours that
only got one stick i remember really
yeah because the band was barely funded
the band was basically stuff they made
in wood shop
that would make a sound so you'd have
five or six dudes we had this real
this kid named brian st pierre out there
and he was really like the first kind of
black white kid ever the first white kid
ever to act like a black kid
and they'd never seen it before and so
he was in mentally handicapped courses
and everything but he
they gave him half a drum
you know and he'd get he'd get halfway
through a song and he'd be fist fighting
somebody at the concession stand
for a damn airhead or something that kid
was really
real p.o.s p.o.s man real p.o.s
um let's take another call that came in
right here man
i just called in actually i live right
around nashville tennessee
i realized my message was probably a
little long something i wouldn't really
listen to
i just want to let you guys know like
reiterate if you guys are ever around
the town nick
theo you know any of the uh kingston
family like i got some good places all
around nashville some families some
property i'd love to show you guys
around
show you a good time really now as right
now this guy sounds either like a
super nice guy or murderer
i like to show you around the property
if i'm a woman if i'm drunk outside of a
bar
that's death oh we got a big private
lake
let you guys come fish catch some big
old bass instead of
ken's baby bass and i really have a good
time
hit me up my name is kyle sickle around
nashville tennessee
all right kyle wow i appreciate that man
it's really nice of you and i will hit
you up
and i would love to come out there and
catch a bass you know
you ever reeled in something big riley
mount
um i haven't um i
i mean i love going fishing i am super
bad at it
um i haven't done it as much i did it
when i was
in scouts um that's when i would always
fish with a few of my friends
fellow scouts and um and do you guys
have like a no man left behind kind of
thing like that like what is their
what's the mantra yeah um
yeah man we are always like we leave no
man behind
we leave no trace behind um that was
that
yeah well yeah that was actually our
thing um our scout motto
not our motto um i forgot what was
called one of our sayings
um leave no trace behind um and or scout
slogan that's what it is
and that basically means like we leave
no trash we leave everything better than
how we found it like if we're at a
campsite
you know if there's a few you know
pieces of plastic on the ground you know
we'd pick it up
throw it throw it out on the way out
leave it better than how we found it
wow hey man man
um yeah thank you for the fishing offer
you know that's a nice that's really
nice man and i will hit you up
and i will come fish you know i
appreciate that uh
that'll make me feel more you know at
home here
and getting into the mma has made me
feel more home
you know just going in just keep going
back even though it's like yeah i go in
and
some of the people recognize me and say
you know or they're super friendly but
it also makes you feel a little
uncomfortable when people
not that they're trying to make you feel
uncomfortable with just
um there's just a different it's like
it's cool
but it's also it's like okay you know i
i want to take the class i want to be
when you i start thinking that they
think differently of me and so then i
start
it's just in my head you know um so
anyway
all all they've been is really welcoming
and
and yeah just starting to feel a little
bit more confident about
like when i was young i was just so i
just didn't have any confidence man
you know i just didn't have any man who
got you into taekwondo
really um i've
actually kind of wanted to do it myself
um i just wanted to learn martial arts
self-starter they call it
right and i just wanted to
from the very beginning i've always
wanted to earn black belt that's the
same thing with scouts from the very
beginning
joining cub scouts i've always wanted to
become an eagle scout that was like my
thing and i had to make it
um so i did the same exact thing for um
taekwondo
i loved it i'm glad i did you know
there's something real powerful about
having self-control is real powerful
right you know because i'm the other end
of that where i've struggled with
oh jesus christ i struggled sorry
sorry um i've just struggled i've
struggled with it
you know i'm sure that you know so
doing masturbation and that kind of
stuff i really struggle with that
you know it's hard it's hard to do it
man
it's hard to not do it that's what i
mean so
um what else are we talking about man
breaking up with your old wireless
provider
just got a whole lot easier thanks to
mint mobile
that's right they were the first company
to sell premium wireless service
online only and now mint mobile is
introducing their unlimited data plan
for just 30 bucks a month let that sink
in
an unlimited plan for 30 bucks
how much is your soon to be x wireless
provider charging you
think about it how much are they
charging you you know
for people that hate their phone bill
and are ready to cut ties with big
wireless
mint mobile offers their premium
unlimited plan
for just 30 bucks a month that's premium
unlimited think about limits
now don't think about them that's mint
mobile
by going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail
mint mobile passes significant savings
on to you that's how they do it
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text and high-speed data delivered
on the nation's largest 5g network
if you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their 7 day money
back guarantee
break up with big wireless and switch to
mint mobile this sounds like quite a
deal
to get your new unlimited wireless plan
for just 30 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com
theo that's mint m-o-b-i-l-e
dot com slash t-h-e-o
cut your unlimited wireless bill to 30
bucks a month
at mint mobile.com slash
theo you know i was uh my fingers are
hurting from i think becoming a man
that's what i'm feeling like
um and i know that sounds crazy but
you know i think i've been to four of
these uh
you know i'm doing mma and so i've been
to four classes now
and i know look i'm not saying that i
know anything
i know absolutely nothing
but i just
i don't know it's weird my hands always
feel like i don't know what to do with
them
and then suddenly just a little my hands
feel like
a little bit more like they're gonna be
okay
that's all that's the only little thing
i just start to notice that
my hands will they'll be okay
like uh i can't explain it it's just
they feel a little more confident that
don't mean try me i don't want somebody
to you know come at me or hit me with a
sword or shoot me or nothing or
you know do something you know do
anything but
yeah it just feels interesting
um but that's what they feel
it's the same feeling if you've been
practicing a guitar and you get those
things on your
fingers what are they called rally do
you know
calluses yes it's just like that
all right
i remember one year we got into some
racial stuff at halloween uh
my dad had gotten some cinnamon sticks
you know when somebody i think maybe
like a cuban person or something had
left them somewhere i don't know someone
got him he got him
but uh or he might have gotten my dad
used to go to south america a lot and do
some stuff i don't know what he was
doing he might have been
probably running around on my mom but i
don't know i was you know i was a child
and uh
anyway so we were all excited with the
cinnamon sticks so we were like oh let's
go
let's do halloweening as cinnamon
cinnamon sticks family
and so we got everybody out there dude
and this is back when you could do
something darker without getting raced
out
you know nowadays i jump in some yellow
paint and run out there
and people say oh you're uh you're being
hateful
to asian people i jump in red paint they
say oh you're being hateful to native
americans i jump in
you know i try to do a little bit of
cinnamon sticking as a family and they
say oh you're being uh hateful you know
this you're being black hateful to
blacks black people or black
culture and but back then nobody it
wasn't like that
people were you could be a cinnamon
stick at halloween
you know and i remember a day when in
america you could be
a cinnamon stick at halloween
and not get called out for racial
injustice
people are like you hate you are you
being hateful
like i'm being cinnamon that's all i'm
being
and every cinnamon everybody loves
cinnamon
you know and i long for a day like that
in this country again
you know i really long for a day like
that
um but the disease i feel like is
lightening up
i feel like people are i don't know
what's going on
you know i don't know i feel like with
the disease
corvid or
lung aids some people call it
um i can't i am i'll just
i am shocked that we shut down the world
but we didn't really know what to do i
think
we didn't really know there's no people
can
you can't monday morning quarterback a
pandemic
but i feel like we should have let it
seems like
people that are highly susceptible
should have been given maybe a
government stipend give them something
help them get
stay safe and let the rest of the world
operate
that's what i feel like we should have
tried to do
but one thing about being a free country
is sometimes
everybody has their everybody wants to
do their own thing
and they can you know
they can all right let's take one or two
more calls uh here we go
hey theo uh this is mike jenner calling
uh just wanna say hey man
thanks for all you do um
i'm a recovering addict two years sober
over two years sober
gang man congratulations mike
two years baby dosagnos baby them
spanish years daddy you got em
uh off of that methamphetamine crazy
i never did any meth man
and i always wanted to smoke crack
honestly
i never did uh smoke any crack and i
always
wanted to
to know what it was like have you had a
high drug experience raleigh
i've not you you will know me as the
most
innocent man i mean you know i'm a
christian eagle scout so i'm like the
most innocent guy
that you will probably ever meet what's
the highest stimulant you've been on
what something have you been on
um i want to say the highest thing would
probably be
when i got my wisdom teeth pulled out um
other than that i mean what were you on
brother
uh on that yes would they have you on it
was
a gassed you out yes oh hell yeah it was
uh that's crazy dude there's videos of
that where you can watch asian people
getting gassed out it's like a
because a lot of asian people do sorry
i'm generalizing in
uh there's a lot of unique japanese
videos where they do
different artistic stuff with laughing
gas have you seen any of that i have
yes but see i'm not
i remember when i got my was you know
how wisdom or people who get their
wisdom teeth pulled out and they're like
slowly waking up afterwards they're like
you know they do funny stuff all the
time
um that wasn't me i remember that like
my arm
like my arms were up on the seat um but
and i have pictures my mom took pictures
of me
like that it was funny but other than
that i didn't really do anything funny
like i was conscious enough to know like
like i saw i still remember seeing the
camera on me i'm like
put that away no yeah i mean other than
that i didn't really do anything too
funny
um it wasn't it was an interesting
experience i gotta say
hell yeah man yeah look man getting
gassed out and doing that
and uh getting your teeth pulled out
that's that's the only thing
see if every time people got high they
had to pull their teeth out that should
be the rule
people want to do crack you want to do a
little bit of math impediments
then they rip a molar they freaking
take an incisor out every time you do
every time you you know
get gassed up you know or get blotched
out on some percocets they pull another
tooth and once you're toothless no more
drugs for you
that's how it should be done
would you throw out a couple more teeth
to get one you know to go another round
you think
well uh that i'm currently getting an
implant put in
and oh yeah boy and i had to basically
um there's this one um this one uh
oral surgeon he uh there's like this
tooth that wouldn't come down so he was
trying to pull it down
that took about a year and it didn't
come down
so i went to a different orthodontist
and he was like no no i was supposed to
go over then down
so then we were like okay so we wasted a
whole year going down so we tried going
over and down
but that wouldn't work after a year
later because of the first guy that was
trying to pull it down
so then they had to end up taking it out
and it was like a shark tooth it was
really curved it was really weird
um so then yes i got it taken out dorsal
exactly um i got it taken out and then
now i'm trying to it's like i think year
five or something of this something
crazy like it's been since high school
praise god trying to get one tooth out
of you yep and so now
we are trying to get or i'm trying to
get an implant of where it's i think
so the space is it was too big for two
teeth but too small
for three teeth so i think we're just
gonna do three small teeth going in
wow so it's gonna be interesting for
sure three small
teeth man it's been years
of doing this but and it's almost done
everybody's got their vietnam baby you
know that's the wild thing man let's
finish this call up right here
uh but hey man i just wanted to say
uh with your emotions two
years sober and i'm still
feeling the uh
the emptiness uh
i'm trying i got a full-time job a great
job i'm a
great employee i haven't missed a day of
work in over a year and a half
i love it i love my job i'm outside all
day that saved my life but man
i feel empty man when i'm not working i
feel empty
yeah you know i i can really relate to
that
you know sometimes i notice i'll get
i just have to keep doing work i can't
sit there and not do work
because then it's like if i don't have
work then i'm almost just kind of left
with who i
am or something
so i just lean so heavy into work man
um let's hear more
uh anyway
people got it worse than i do i know
that uh
all i gotta say is gang gang gang bro
congrats on your two years man and um
[Music]
yeah you know life is a it's a
survivor's game
i mean it's a survivor's game man
and sometimes it's you know sometimes i
don't want to take care of myself really
sometimes i get tired of taking care of
myself
i just wanna
let somebody else do it
you know where i just wanna but that's
where you pull it up that's where we get
that's where we get
g up you know
have a half a red bull or something
you know so no you do you don't have the
right word you don't have there's
nothing to say sometimes it's just
we just keep battling man that's it
we keep it cruising you know we do our
own thing
all right we got one last call here man
and uh
i want to thank all the callers and and
um
985-664-9503
as always is the hotline you can call
and be a part of this show
um all right let's take one more call
right here
hey theo this is darren i'm calling from
indiana
what's up darren indiana
it's a spanish four
in in indiana indian
oh indian i did not know that yeah
uh i just wanted to say that i really
support your move
out of the los angeles metropolis i've
lived there
i'm from i came from toronto i lived in
los angeles
now i'm living in indiana uh you know
it's just a whole nother view of america
i know you grew up more
rural in louisiana but man i think you
need to reconnect with that because
while you might be scared the benefit's
far away
the fear you you just you look around
you're like oh whoa what's that that's a
blade of grass
oh well what's that that's a leaf on a
tree
these are things you forget about when
you're in l.a there's just endless
there's no way to escape it like other
than going into the ocean you know and
then
you'll drown yeah that's true you know
la it's just it's
a it's a never-ending
you know it's a never-ending and
look it's not a move you know
it's a test drive um and
but thank you for the well wishes man a
lot of well-wished calls came in
you know a lot of people just saying hey
uh you know it's exciting and
you know stay positive and you know i
had that trouble last week at big lots
and
you know ran into some issues over there
and uh
and and so you know
but you know i'm just rolling with the
punches man
you know and i'm trying to find things
that that that will connect me
because it's real easy for me to get
disconnected
you know it's easy for me to be
disconnected man
so so i'm trying to find little things
to connect me and
to just be a part of my own life man to
stay active in my own life
to get up each day and say all right
this is you know
and if i lose half the day to say hey
man let's make a comeback here in the
second half
you know we can do it um
you know we can do it we just got to
keep going
that's all we can do riley mao do you
think yes sir
that's all we can do you heard him
ladies and gentlemen uh
thank you guys for joining us this week
uh i'm gonna go out on
the same way that we came in man
you know out here riding into the
apocalypse of time
with uh with stevie starlight time is no
stranger again september 26th i will be
in cedar rapids iowa that's outdoors
um trying to get back on uh doing some
dates
and uh gonna hopefully tip a netflix
special here
soon so we want to i gotta
do the material um i got up for the
first time the other night in nashville
and
we'll talk about that next episode um
about what that was like i'm gonna go
back and get up uh tonight
and uh and yeah just
just keep going you know just keep going
so congratulations on the guys that hit
a couple years of sobriety and anybody
else that's out there struggling
um and anybody that's struggling in
silence
uh man it's
there's nothing tougher man than
than than struggling in silence
but you can do it man woman
everyone thank you for being here riley
thank you for having me on all right
let's go out with a little bit of stevie
starlight time is no stranger
[Music]
the fire the gender reveal fire is still
burning and shout out to all the firemen
and fire women out there fighting that
blaze and
i think it's consumed like 70 000 acres
or something now and uh
you know and they still don't know if
it's a boy or a girl isn't that crazy
really wow
[Music]
so
this time there's no danger
[Music]
told me to be patient
wait and see
[Music]
stevie starlights
there's no danger
you